non pas de n'y a pas eu de raids du
couffo que j'ai récupéré le chat
il n'y a pas eu de pas eu de raids donc
je ne sais pas qui suit qui suivent à
avoir on va voir sur le chat un
paria qui comme joueur
on sait pas du inde usa
c'est russie usa
c'est chose faite
ah oui allez pu permettre aussi très
important
monkey actions du boss donc ces numéros
cinq russes contre le numéro cinq
américains artemiev robson ça doit être
numéro 6 contre numéro 6
liang under control shipping co crush
contre goliath china costing pays qu'ils
faisaient et shuvalova
on n'est pas chauve à leur accrochage
valley
je propose qu'on regarde un peu cette
partie en fait
partie juniors féminines parce que c'est
vrai que c'est souvent là que ça joue au
final
c'est vrai que c'est souvent là qu'il ya
des punto ce qu'ils sont mis
son club est ouvert le bal shankland et
shahi valley
va chier du coup
on en vend de la grave
ce très beau nom des parties en duo
comme ça
shay valley
je pense qu'avoir une victoire facile de
la russie personne on va voir pour le
moment c'est par là que ça se joue en il
faut attendre encore dans un petit quart
d'heure ça devrait se décanter
il faut attendre il ya beaucoup
d'échiquier là en même temps bourse
ajoute partout en face on s'est un peu
l'ouverture par tous
ça a coupé le truc ouais ok merci bien
vu
c'est le bordel ouais il ya beaucoup
d'échecs et en même temps
complexe
je zappe à fond quand un truc c'est
qu'il ya six échiquier donc pour un peu
voir le match aux apps est un
sinon on voit pas trop vite on voit pas
trop ce que tu peux pas trop voir ce qui
se passe le format fait qu'on peut pas
vraiment comprendre qui est mieux dans
le match si on s'y intéresse pas en
allant vite
occupé tour à écouter les olympiades en
ligne il n'y a aucun pays qui a pris
vraiment ça au sérieux
et donc
c'est des règles très étrange et c'est
la russie les usa qui sont en finale
mais ah bon vous voilà ça
ça pas vraiment
ça aucune valeur quoi sportive
car action a pris ça au sérieux après ça
pu avoir de la valeur pour des pays où
qui gagne jamais rien à rien parce que
ça peut leur faire avoir comme au
kazakhstan dé
et enfin pas du sponsoring mais quand tu
as de l'argent de l'état quant à je
perds le mot
prend le mot est tout simple jeudi sur
le bout de la langue mais je ne trouve
pas les subventions et voilà il ya
certains pays où ça pouvait servir à
avoir des subventions donc à récupérer
un peu d'argent public un peu de vos
impôts c'était un peu l'intérêt de de la
fin pas pour pas pour nous mais tu vas
pour certains pays c'est un peu de
gratter les impôts des contribuables
quoi c'était un peu le un peu l'objectif
pour
par exemple pour l'équipe du kazakhstan
mais ça devait pas être la seule
ça va pas durer c'est l'équipe qui a
souhaité tenter
de choper de la subvention
des 5 c'est pas mal joué je crois que
sur foot france et 5 à tour ses 8
et 4 b 6
c'est très bien joué ça fait une
lentille peyrelongue il ya fou prend
tour à ses mythes bécade b6 bouffe tour
à 6
mais bon
j'y croirai pas mais elle va pas lever
toute façon
il naquit passé qui pensent que le chien
pas fait pipi depuis hier soir mais en
fait non elle a dû faire pipi pendant
qu'elle courait li na s'est pas rendu
compte
à tour ses 620 de vente pour les noirs
[Musique]
denses et si cet emprunt b6 vous prend
1,7
toute façon c'était sûr que ça allait
pas être jouait trop compliqué à ce
niveau
j'ai un fils en est sûre je sais pas
mais c'est pas possible à des infos qui
a faim on est sorti plusieurs fois mais
d'après l'irna la dernière fois que le
chien a fait pipi c'est hier à 20h
et je vois pas dans quel monde un chien
fait pas pipi pendant 22 heures sans
avoir
l'impression d'avoir un problème de
santé en fait
enfin je pense que si tu fais
si tu fais pas
tu peux pas ne pas ne pas ne pas aller
aux toilettes pendant 22 heures
consécutives quoi enfin ou alors t'es
vraiment très très malade mais sinon
c'est pas possible
donc à mon avis doit être en train de
courir à la fais un truc à la vue la
plage elle adore la plage selon tant
qu'elle n'est pas allée à la cour eut
elle était tellement heureuse à la faire
pipi pendant qu'elle courait quoi ou un
truc comme ça je vois pas d'autre
explication
ou sinon elle serait très malade elle
sera l'article de la mort quand même
pas j'ai cette impression j'ai
l'impression que tu peux pas ne pas
pisser pendant 20 heures
qu'elle demande à sortir quand elle a
vraiment envie donc elle a même pas
demandé à sortir et ou non mais c'est
sûr
je pense pas que car moi je les ressorti
en plus à 11 heures enfin il ya ce n'est
pas possible
enfin j'espère un
j'aime bien sûr l'arrivée officielle
c'est qu'il montre pas tout le temps les
échiquiers non plus en fait c'est
magnifique il montre un peu les têtes
des joueurs les machins brabo un
très heureux de leur live en fait
en fait ils ont compris qu'on pouvait
pas vraiment suivre et du coup ils
suivent pas non plus en fait ces foules
freestyle en fait cette compétition cf
c'est fou le freestyle
mais c'est pour ça en fait que j'avais
inventé ce concept des quinze minutes
qui se passe de joueur en joueur c'était
justement pour les compétitions par
équipe de bath que j'avais pensé afin de
pouvoir suivre ce genre de compétition
j'avais eu cette idée au cours de la
deûle approach s league en réalité pour
vous expliquer tout ça parce que pendant
la prod classique je m'étais rendu
compte que j'ai avec les quatre joueurs
qui jouent en même temps déjà 4 on
n'arrivait pas vraiment à suivre c'était
plus facile à suivre que ça quand même
parce qu'il y avait une évolution dans
le match c'était un peu plus simple on
arrivait déjà pas à suivre donc je
m'étais district ou en fait que les 15
minutes elle se partage entre les
joueurs qu'on puisse suivre une partie
après l'autre
et à
[Musique]
du coup ce par la suite de ces
compétitions claqué aux fins claqué au
sol de ce format de la prod chelsea qui
était plutôt pas mal c'était pour
l'améliorer en réalité mais il était
plutôt pas mal de base que j'avais fait
ça a eu en fait ils ont empiré quoi
et la prod classique ce sera vendredi on
a une équipe mais je dois vous dire que
c'est j'ai quasiment aucune info les
joueurs sont en galère en plus -
vendredi je pourrai pas les aider j'ai
pas le jour le plus humble de ma vie a
passé
en tout cas de voir le nine olympiades
2022 je sais pas si on continue à les
faire je pense qu'ils vont continuer en
fait ça a l'air d'être tellement mauvais
d'intéresser personnes que je pense que
ça va continuer cette compétition
l'approach à celui qui intéressait
vraiment pas mal de monde s'est arrêté
mais je pense que ça du coup ça ça
devrait continuer
donc
voilà pour commenter vrai
mais ça c'est fini a lancé vendredi mais
c'est en 3 + 0 une année à une arena 2
heures en fait ya vingt ans c'était bien
et ils ont réussi en faire quelque chose
de pas terrible
il avait un format bien ils ont réussi à
en faire un format pas terrible on verra
bien mais ils disent que c'est une
saison de transition et que ça reprendra
pour de vrai l'année prochaine
c'est vraiment très dommage de ne pas
avoir fait la prochaine explique
justement et ses compétitions sur
internet pendant le confinement je
trouve ça assez dommage d'avoir attendu
qu'on n'ait plus envie de voir des
échecs sur internet pour le faire
mais du coup sur internet et regarde qui
vérifiaient possible tricherie ou alors
après il sert pas à grand chose non plus
on se cache pas
hop là mais petrossian et
[Musique]
après il aurait pu continuer la compet
en mode en mode fun et réduire le nombre
d'équipés f1 y avait des solutions en
fait pour cette fraude chasse league il
y avait clairement des solutions
on n'aurait pas empêché la tricherie
tournant internet mais
ça on ne les empêchera jamais hein
on va voir on va attendre un toute façon
john's et qui a pas eu de confinement
vraiment en hiver oui mais avait plutôt
à des chats que you put s c'est pas
vraiment une question de confinement
c'est une question qui avait plu tournoi
tous les tournants ont été annulés donc
il y avait pas tournant à cet hiver
maintenant tous les tournois ont repris
donc tu as envie de voir le norwich est
cette envie de voir d'autres choses en
fait
là par exemple qu'est ce que tu as envie
de voir t'as plus envie de voir les
olympiades en ligne donc qui compte pour
pas grand chose même si c'est la finale
où le norwich s avec karl scène n'est
pas offrir ou dja et rapporte donc avec
numéro un numéro 2 numéro 6 mondial et
plus grands espoirs
des échecs en fait qu'est-ce que t'as
plus envie de regarder
tu regardes une compétition
avec matt ce matin merci à toi
ah ouais c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'en fait c'est mal calé dans le
calendrier
faye times m écoute on va voir pour le
moment c'est pas clair et peut-être
marcher quatre fous des 4,5 à voir là le
truc c'est qu'on n'a pas une vision
globale du match donc c'est difficile
j'ai l'impression que c'est à peu près
égale partout
enfin y'a pas de différence faite
il ya quelques petits avantages par ci
par là
mais là ça a l'air de bien se passer le
jeu sur cases noires 1
donc on va voir ce qui se passe
bon alors ça joue sajou
va voir comment ça évolue
et encore les em aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ça va faire j'ai quatre ailes ce à quoi
ça va attaquer le roi
je trouve vraiment bien que la prod chez
stx et qu'à terme ça peut être une façon
d'avoir un tournant avec de la team qui
peut faire une deuxième hors du top 10
afin d'avoir des revenus bah ouais mais
en fait ils ont fait une autre erreur
c'est en fait ils ont aussi enlevé les
avants pouvait jouer par équipe
en mode moi j'aurais pu se fonde sur une
équipe avec les saab et tout et on
aurait pu faire une team bitstream slash
blackheath temps en fait ils ont enlevé
ça pour mettre des pays et du coup ça
empêche les influenceurs de pouvoir
prendre en main une équipe et donc
théoriquement avoir du sponsoring ils
ont aussi pris cette direction qui a un
petit peu embêtante
mais du coup ils ont un peu enlevé
tout ce qui était bien due forme à quoi
notre trouveront pareil mais tu vas
karine ferco candidat macho a bien bien
bien jouer perso c'est vrai bien pour
les blancs en fait ça va attaquer sa
conférence la direction sur les
différences avec les olympiades aucune
la différence c'est que les olympiades
c'est je crois au niveau du prize pool
s'est financée par les fédérations et la
prod chez slicks et chaises comme kim et
le prize pool mais ça aucune différence
moi je vais pas jouer non on n'en
vendredi je peux pas jouer je serai là
pour commenter mais je peux pas jouer
pour convaincre c'est bien joué et des
oeufs car elle et prend du relief 6 d'un
match c'est ouais ça va gagner pour
shuvalova ça
ma vraie prochain si c'est moi qui
m'occupe de l'équipe donc c'est un peu
différent
différence comme je m'occupe de l'équipe
c'est plus drôle pour moi
je pense fait tu vas voir même damage
six cavaliers f6 et d'un match 7 maths
je vois pas comment tu empêches l'ordi
didams et si ces gars là parce qu'ils
touchent le cavalier kireev 6 roi et
puis de force et il défense a
alors dit défense avait ses chances
incroyables 1 bat soissons dame sait si
ces forces et si on importe quel au coût
de ces dames h600 fait
puisqu'elle va l'épreuve 6 et se termine
à dos d'ailleurs sur dame c'est cette
même cavalier 6-3 ici d'un machisme quoi
ici qu'à valider cinq
là ça donne quoi quel assez chaud
bassalah revient pour arte f
la ses qualités de plus pour lyon mais
c'est chaud
à les kids et qui joue pas mal là cette
game
c'est pas mal pourquoi j'annonce et
chose ce match
le discours du coach bien pas vraiment
parce qu'en fait la prod classiques des
années précédentes c'était quatre
joueurs maintenant ces neuf joueurs et
en vrai la grosse difficulté ça va être
la technique donc on pourra pas faire de
discours de coach ni rien parce qu'il
faut deux caméras les joueurs ont pas le
droit de parler donc non il ya plein de
trucs
qui vont pas
il aurait fallu qu'il fasse un truc on
peut se parler entre les parties où on
peut faire un peu de storytelling
mais bon ils ont dit que c'était une
saison de transition donc savait pas
vocation à être spécialement bien
pas on ne sait pas exactement ce qu'ils
ont voulu faire dans l'idéal quoi c'est
un truc un peu écho plus
mais ils sont censés refaire un format
un peu plus sympa l'année prochaine
ça alors n 10 malgré deux saisons c'est
d'exister pour pas rendre la transition
trop abrupte c'est exactement ça
quand ils ont voulu faire un truc cours
parce qu'il ya trop de choses dans le
calendrier je sais pas comment ils s'y
sont pris mais en tout cas
on va juste 3g cette tour à la fuite en
fait c'est
terrible
à roye g7 elle veut g5 toujours là je
suis damage 6,3 g 8 cavaliers si c'est
bien vrai
maintenant c'était bien joué le g5
j'avais pas vu
donc trois sets et maintenance et
arrache quatre cavaliers absiskey prend
1,8 à
ce parent d'un truc mauvais
volontairement l'oci mais en fait c'est
juste que le format il est offert à ses
obligés d'être une compétition courts
qui dure sept huit jours donc faire un
truc par équipes sur sept jours c'est
pas évident
après moi je pense que ça aurait été
sympa de faire des trucs en 4 v 4 comme
on avait fait avec élimination directe
plutôt de faire des arénas avec neuf
joueurs en même temps je sais pas trop
comment suivre une équipe de neuf en
fait ça me paraît tellement difficile de
déjà en cas de v4 c'était dur mais là en
9 v 9 je sais pas du tout comment ça va
être possible de suivre cette prochaine
ligue en fait
ça me paraît extrêmement compliqué
haye avait dame prend f6 à la fin ok
c'était dur à voir sortir ex
c'est sûr que tu vas gérer ouais enfin
cher ça va être difficile de rendre le
truc intéressant
surtout dont 3 + 0 tu peux pas on suivra
un joueur après l'autre on verra comment
on fait
après dans le neuf et un choix forcément
des nomades je ne vois pas ces focus et
puis ça mais en fait pas à neuf joueurs
qui jouent en même temps
même si tu regardes une interne et un v
9 en trois +0 fitrat les autres partis
donc en fait si ton mec gaye que sa
partie la plus serrée mais qui perd 5 5
4 la partie avec une valve enfin c'est
assez calme tu suis un match de foot et
on te dit ok tu peux suivre entre la
zéro et 10e minute 10e 20e 20e ou 30e on
va dire tu dis entre la 50e et la 60e
c'est cool mais t'as pas le score donc
mail suivant un but peut-être que tu es
mené 3 0 tu sais pas
c'est vraiment comme regarder un match
de foot vient de là 80 la 90e minute on
ne donne pas le score en fait tu peux
regarder ça peut être cool
mais en fait juste même si un but tu
sais pas - tu dois être content pas
content tu en sais rien en fait c'est un
peu bizarre
la comparaison devient le foie ou un
match de tennis sur garde un jeu mais tu
vas y c'est premier set le deuxième le
troisième tu sais pas où on en est dans
le match je sais pas ce qui se passe
donc c'est impossible à ce fin c'est pas
marrant cheap c'est un peu comme on suit
là tu vois on regarde la partie mais
c'est difficile de se passionner parce
qu'on n'a pas une vision globale du
match tout le monde joue en même temps à
la différence des sacs battle l'esa
battle on joue les uns après les autres
donc on sait enfin on connaît le score
on voit l'évolution du match là en fait
on voit pas on sait pas juste à des
coûts qui cliquent mais bon ça qui quoi
qu artemiev va gagner
bien on va gagner
gatti on va sûrement gagné kosteniuk et
mieux c'est de partir elle est vraiment
importante en attendant j'ai eu le flair
parce que celle là c'est celle qui
tourne le plus de game
je n'ai pas suivi la suite avec la
cadence
ah oui tu es passionné fancy celle d
ollars du coup on s'est mal compris
ouais ok ok
donc pas trop comment on va assumer une
nouvelle fois c'est une saison de
transition ils ont essayé de faire un
truc
à vous avoir à voir ce que ça donne
peut-être ce sera marrant
allez spitzer ça va reprendre alors là
aussi marrant il y aura des matchs de ce
pitch est cependant le championnat du
monde
on verra si c'est stan wright ou pas
grace is and white ou pas
à cheval y en a le plus marqué
dans ce que j'ai suivi steak rami
calendes
xhaka effet retour de tous rêvent de me
ça ça doit être nul
mais ça peut de choc
face à peu de chocs de partout il ya
beaucoup de positions complexes j'ai dit
que chantait bien causé nuque c'est
juste pour le non ce n'est pas la
position
belge qui n'a par contre y'a qu'à relief
trois dames proches trois matches un
garage qui n'a ça gagne
artemiev ça devrait gagner
du box à 2 rétro
et shipping co ça te ferait perdre
et ça joue vraiment de partout
à la le roi va se cachant à deux quand
même
quand même mieux pour les blancs
c't'histoire même si ça doit être nul
en fin de vie j'ai fait récemment plus
de jus à la fin c'est normal au bowie
début des années 2000 noël
ouais c'est sympa de faire ch pendant le
championnat du monde mais en fait c'est
pendant les jours de repos lorraine dit
très important
mais ça j'ai déjà écrit pour dire que je
les que je les suivrai pas parce que
le match de championnat du monde c'est
trop éprouvant à celui-là je sais pas
pourquoi la fed alger 4 c'est stupide
comme coupât à elle veut dame prend f7
j'espère qu'elle a bien calculé et à la
dan des indes am acad donc en fait c'est
très bien joué
ça ça vadrot
à retenir ce qui fait un peu de la merde
une nouvelle fois les américains qui
retourne un peu le match
fatalement qui à la copie pas son mot de
passe terrible
vraiment sa clique bien côtes américains
à
ça c'est un très très bizarre
by kids et qui a fait nul sa part être
une très mauvaise décision en vue d
autres échiquiers parce qu ils sont deux
à mener 1-0 elle avait une position où
elle pouvait tenter de gagner mais le
match a trop de partis en même temps ça
suit pas sakic au hasard les parties ont
pas de lyon donc ça veut dire que si
artemiev la gagne ça va faire pinto et
artemiev il est quand même pas loin de
là gagner celle-là
alors là la paille kids et qui a pas
pris la bonne décision mais bon toutes
les parties se jouent en même temps
c'est difficile
c'est difficile de suivre
dans mon cas
ça va jouer sur celles à deux parties
si artemiev la gagne c'est terminé en
fait
facile de trouver le gain tourbe et 6 3
7 5 pour prendre trois points f5
ils rendent pour ça la tour france 3
points f5 tour des trois tours bessette
haye sur oise g8 ya roi justice menace
mater sur wife 6-3 6-3 roi des sept noms
ça devrait pas suffire sa
voix je crois tour 17 c sur
roy fui 3 6 3 17 qui est bien ici
angers 5 temps proches qu'à 3,5 ce n'est
pas gagnant ça
ça une belle tête un an peut-être tout
reprend g7 comprend h quatre tours h7 en
fait il a fait des six
pour détroit ça c'est roy e 5
3 des 5 tours des trois-rois cistre
trois rois f5 tour des trois
rois des quatre tours prend des quatre
maintenant d'en changer cet enfant h45
courage de
f5 virait tourer wife six tours d un des
sept échecs tricherie je sais pas si ça
gagne
à ch4 c'est sûr
à ses tournées à
adé tampon 17 tours h huit matches aïe
aïe aïe ça gagne alors oui la rater ah
mais ça gagne quand même 17 ont fondé
cette courageuse huit matchs c'était
joli os j'ai vu que après
et là le roi du mauvais côté la même
avec leur en acheter la tour en d5 c'est
nul mais le roi est du mauvais côté donc
soit il va gagner la partie 6 km
quelle mauvaise décision de paille qui
faisait quand même de faire là nul parce
qu'en fait le score logique
du score le score logique dans toutes
les autres parties elle a bouffé la
feuille
fait elle devait risque
elle devait risqué parce que robson
c'était quasi sûr qu'il a perdrait
et elle ne pouvait pas se permettre de
laisser un shot comme ça aux russes
surtout finale deux tours technique avec
artemiev qui est très très bon c'était 1
90% de chances de wind
tu montres et le math après le truc
c'est que ça s'est pas jouée en fait et
là ça doit être 3f
à roye fui 3,6 nancy roy g8 roi aussi f7
ton point f 7 tours 8 roy f6 ton rêve 7
et ouais et la sef 7 et tu peux pas
manger le pion parce qu'il ya échec
échec et tout reprend ouais voilà c'est
ce qui va faire donc on va le voir sur
l'échiquier et tourcoing fc normalement
il sait mater avec trois tours
et ça gagne le match ça enfin le mini
match
et oui artemiev gacina ça fait deux
points
et là je sais pas trop pourquoi ça joue
encore mais ça joue
façon la crf quai c'est un peu de la
mare loterie
ça va abandonner de façon le match est
gagné mais là on voit que les joueurs
ils savent même pas que c'est gagné en
fait c'est terrible
elle en fait ça fait 1 0 1 pour la
russie
et j'imagine que les joueurs connaissent
pas le score
parce que ça fait aucun aucun sens de
jouer sinon y'a pas de goal avérage en
fait
voilà si tu crois ces deux tours a en
voit les autres am cain qui joue un
probablement non parce qu'à des
décisions très bizarre qui sont prises
mais c'est bizarre dans des compétitions
par équipes ne pas avoir de lien entre
les parties
en tout cas ça fait le boulot
ça fait le poteau pour les rues saint il
gagne deux victoires d'artemis est fait
et gharyen qu'il a
pour les états unis avec pas équité qui
avoue fait la feuille pas utiliser qui a
fait une grosse erreur mais après elle
devait pas avoir les autres partis en
même temps c'est pas possible elle a pas
de directive
victoire logique way littoral logique
victoire logique et facile des rudes
finalement enfin facile ils n'ont pas
été mis en danger je dois dire
ah
oui les pubs les pubs les plus place aux
basses
le spin-off
l'os pour noces
la petite à la petite pub
la petite troupe
l'aspect aux [ __ ]
ouais je m'absente une petite minute je
reviens les amis je reviens je vais me
chercher à voir
c'est magnifique
has been trois minutes de pub dans vos
gueules pas c'est magnifique les pulsars
ans tellement heureux dans cette compét
bîmes la plus basse
ouais j'en enfoiros soit pas en vrai ça
fait un peu de
lui dit qu'il ya là public et a
le spo bosch loges pour bosh
qui partent
pasqua au foot d'ailleurs champion's
league
dortmund qui a ouvert le score
par l'intermédiaire de bellingham et
yachir il faut aussi qu'ils gagnent
magnifique sheriff tiraspol
je serais heureux de
1,1 mais en fait on peut aller voir le
nord ou et tient
très intéressant ça en fait d'aller voir
un peu ce qui se passe au nord où est
ok car la scène rapporte je vois pas là
richard oula ça envoie en fait pierre
houde jacquard yakine [ __ ]
ils envoient diouf en fait sur ou déjà
aux jo
y'a pas moyen djadja il va taper
cardiaque en fait
rien ne tarit pas d'éloges
aya de la belle game boy game
babel est complètement catch and away
quiero
mais si bacaria qu il se met bien sûr
ouja aussi
une compagnie thaï devrait le grand
suisse le grand sud samarraï peu
de place aux candidats quand même après
on verra comment ça se passe pour max et
pour fil rouge à
mais c'est vrai que jah jah way s'il
pouvait battre aujourd'hui car y'a que
ce serait pas mal hein
pour y revenir aux basques de mvl et
peut-être même sortir mvele du top 10
ans incroyable
star ça va reprendre à l'heure quand
même
je pense qu'on est tous pour la russie
dans le match retour
je sais pas si on est tous d'accord
mais je pense qu'on est on est pour la
russie pour le retour
ce que je vous remets trois minutes de
pub ou pas
strauss minutes dépouille à lestrem et
3,8 de pub h vas-y les trois minutes de
pub qui repartent au c'est magnifique
sa part
alors travaillons stable en terme de
points elo il ya un truc c'est une
impression ou pas il perd des points là
depuis un moment
fabiano caruana
fabien ans jusqu'à 3h et c'est reparti
art pas mince ils partent en avance
et non
sur pas de pub pour en remettre j'en ai
mis neuf minutes va précieux temps mais
une 12e minute 3 j'envoie à quoi puis
les estados unidos rebonds les espagnols
ils appellent les états unis et ses
stars los ninos
après c'est juste la traduction des
états unis mais ses mots quand métal
estados unidos
si c'est ici
le sesta l'os windows d'air
[Musique]
mais windows vista à loos
allez
vous le dit moment je peux envoyer des
pubs
1cm america
à tout moment je vous envoie trois
minutes de pub en
est ce que vous voulez que je vous
envoie des pubs pendant les parties
n'est pas avec les blancs à perdre
contre tahri est ménée pose c'est ça le
times et qui peut turbo tilt est née
peau qui pourrait passer s'ils
rapportent gagne aujourd'hui dépôts qui
peut passer en dessous tu rapportes au
classement elo et je vois là richard
on se serait magnifique que rapporte
deviennent top4 monde
rapporte genre le mec que tu attendais
plus et il sort du bois quoi
un genre de robin des bois richard des
bois
non mais c'est ouf quand même non
23e avant de france est sorti du bois
mais il y retourner
richard il peut il peut jordan dubois et
peu il peut sortir du genre den
c'est beau quoi
richard sort du genre de nos ça reprend
c'est magnifique je suis tellement
heureux que ça reprenne bon on en voit
un peu on va où moi je pense qu'on
regarde à montregard katia au bon voilà
on regarde cas théâtre c'est bien europe
mais c'est ouf ça quand même quand il
pense richard
si richard devient top4 monde quand même
c'est le truc qu'on s'attende auquel on
s'attendait pas du tout non
non mais vraiment vous y attendiez ou
pas ce truc là peut-être faire le fou
d'eidos
magnifique un
rapport tu n'étais pas dans le dernier
alors on est bien d'accord
moi pas du tout je sais même pas qui est
riche à richard rapporte le mec fait top
4 mondial ce soit bon ou pas mais je
l'aï d'un choc pour top 4 mondial quand
même pas elle est déjà top 6 mélie avec
l'étape de monde on en mode on le
connaît pas ça me rappelle un peu
l'ascension de mvl bon le connaissait
plus fin plus well et tout d'un coup en
fait max il était chez pas top 8 9 10 et
tout d'un coup il a fait top 2 il a
écrasé tout le monde pendant tout un été
après lille est loin d'avoir battu car
la scène rapporte
mais je veux dire le mec en fait
rapporte tu le donnaient même pas tu
cochet même pas son nom pour khalifa
candidats honnêtement il ya deux mois de
sa sortie pensais même pas rapporte aux
candidats ça aurait été énorme surprise
par énorme surprise ça aurait été
surprise tu ne serais pas dit il peut y
aller quoi
une 22e maxime bras john
magnus
[Musique]
ouais après avoir qu'à 28 mai pas
caruana tu mets pas digne quand même
objection m dans cinq ans mon édito
rapporte à petit je n'aurais pas écrit
mais hélas hélas aujourd'hui on me dit
rapporte
rapporte apa un mondial bon tu crois pas
non plus mais tu dis c'est possible
en vrai
en vrai aujourd'hui rapporte voir
rapporter un jour champion du monde
bon ça ça paraît toujours très
improbable mais
c'est dans le règne quoi
c'est dans le domaine du possible
les choix ce point-là écoute il gagne
aujourd'hui les cas le top 4 mondial le
bouc
en vraie cité top 4 mondial enfin tu
peux te présenter à tout moment en fait
un jeu dit ça ressemble un peu à maxime
dans le sens où max il avait fait comme
ça hein
hein comme on appelle
une double paire s'est en fait c'est un
peu comme au rugby sur un maul je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué ou en mêlée la
double poussée mais dans un maul défaut
au début ils construisent le molle et
tout d'un coup il avance il le désaxé il
avance
double poussée
après vous avez d'autres doubles mais ça
c'est parce que vous avez l'esprit mal
placé mais mais ça peut exister quoi
en mêlée aussi des fois ils digèrent le
ballon et après il faut une double
poussée est ce que le neuf il a le droit
de
de pousser derrière le 8 d'ailleurs en
mai les
ja riise que le neuf il peut voir
prendre deux trois mètres de recul et
matin
c'est bien ce que je pensais et le 8 et
ce qu'il a le droit de se délier et
faire la même chose ou pas je pense pas
que lui tu es droits dès le 8 et le
droit de se délier non plus
non mais c'était pour confirmer
c'était pour confirmer
j'étais pas bien sûr
en effe marlou peut tenter un croche
pied mais pas beaucoup plus ouais
j'ai fait avec mathieu
c'est quand même pas une heure pour la
paix celle alors on a maxime on amv elle
maso s
romain edouard
maxime lagarde marco materia marc-andré
amaro risi elliott pape a mis en dise et
maël boyer
bas qui a dû a dû se faire remplacer
malheureusement
l'aes sambac irez
vous l'avez oublié cet événement
voilà mans ça joue pas un côté est anase
atone speer on va attendre
mais c'est pas sûr qu'on est tellement
vite se qualifier que ça en fait
il y avait trop de joueurs qui pouvaient
pas donc en vrai on a voulu faire jouer
des jeunes
en vrai le format nous a vraiment pas
épais mais je crois que ça apparaît ip
les autres clubs non plus donc j'ai
aucune idée de quels sont les autres
équipes c'est l'année où il y avait en
face il ya un roster de joueurs qui ont
pas d' équipe
est d'habitude pour la prod casting
habituel il ya peut-être 80 joueurs dans
le roster dont des joueurs du top
mondial tu vois tu vois aronian je vais
pas dire qu'on m'ait demandé mais il
était dans le roster et
demandaient
ils demandaient des sommes x ou y et
cette année il y avait que des joueurs
locaux plus en fait
il y avait personne presque
dans les joueurs forts qui aurait qui
pouvaient renforcer avec deux joueurs
alors que d'habitude on avait au moins
25 ou 30
ça va gagner côté tarifs mais je pense
qu'on va faire fuir ou en demain
firent où il va gagner non
mais n'est pas assez fou en fait un le
tilt
j'ai quasiment envie d'appeler la vidéo
fear ouldja récupère la voiture de
magnus carlsen c'est complètement con
comme titre
c'est facile ça se fait un titre aussi
débile
c'est vraiment très con comme titre
tactique non la dernière fois et magnus
fait voler sa voiture ça pas
spécialement marché c'est plus des
blagues en fait que du foot africain
en vrai ça fonctionne pas super bien
genre de titre le dé la dernière vidéo
qui a bien marché c'était l'inconnue du
top 10 mondial ça c'était vraiment pu ta
clique
après c'était vrai mais ça faisait
vraiment cliqué
merci à hugo 9 d'être là
et d'ailleurs il ya un truc très marrant
sur les vidéos c'est qu'avant les vidéos
qui marchait le moins c'était les best
of et maintenant les vidéos qui marche
le mieux ce sont les best of
marrant
je le fils de materia
le fils de marco materia matteo matériel
et vous avez vraiment petit alors
je pense que hier le frère way
mathieu mais le fils c'était marrant
le fils il doit avoir il aurait même pas
tu n'es quoi mais ce serait beau quand
il serait faux semis foetus quoi
bon je clique 1
les russes qui ont des belles positions
partout ça sent la turbo victoire côté
russe
il a peut-être que ici piano qui n'est
pas bien
on me fait un [ __ ] cliquer avec la
voiture oger qu'avec l' inconnu
avant lui mais bon car jacking m c'était
une petite blague allait quand même
classique ç la
famille encore la partie de rapports de
highway mais il peut il peut être top 4
mondial ce soir si bas le saumon mais ça
va être dur de battre le saumon quand
même
il me fallait l'explication ouais mais
bon enfin
c'était s'était pas vraiment pour le
plus tactique c'était vraiment pour la
blague
dans le cas
magnifique je me fais tag attendait faut
que j'écoute ça t'aurait j'écoute un
truc
mais je sais pas en fait
je sais pas en fait je vois jouer un
truc fantastique je fais pas que sur
twitter par plusieurs personnes
j'arrive pas à trouver les extraits
oui c'est magnifique c'est vraiment vrai
en fait je me suis fait
je me suis fais et dead je me suis fais
aidé avec
avec mon prénom proches je me suis fais
et dead je suis aidé aide à ces
magnifiques
c'est magnifique
je suis très heureux mais en fait la
vidéo était longue je pensais que ce
serait des bus tata toute fin
je suis très très heureux il n'y a que
des bonnes nouvelles en fait aujourd'hui
c'est magnifique
kevin devraient être interdits comme
prénom elle s'est mariée ce magnifique
c'est une erreur d'autoriser les kevin
quoi c'est extraordinaire je suis très
heureux quoi je suis aidé a dit quoi
ah mais c'est magnifique
le z le z qui ne respectent pas mon
prénom et raya pas puis en france et 4
c'est ça hiller qui avait lieu quatre
cavaliers f6 mais terrible kosteniuk en
fait
c'est le z qui a dit ça ouais
c'est le z qui a 10 arrêts
en ce très beau qu'un prénom kevin
magnifique
croix le z qui marchent dessus quoi
ça va gagner pour kosteniuk
c'est magnifique
magnifique non mais je faisais tagué sur
twitter je vais vous avez plusieurs
genres libration et qu'est-ce qui se
passe
marrant marc marans
je suis vraiment je suis vraiment pas
bien quoi parce qu'entre mon prénom est
mon nom je suis rarement dans la merde
en fait
je suis dans la sauce les amis je suis
dans la sauce
là je suis dans une sauce je suis dans
une sauce terrible
j'ai le prénom et le nom qui vont pas
quoi je suis je vraiment mal
ce qu'à l'origine kevin c cents
gv aucun rapport c'est juste mes parents
qui m'ont appelé comme ça
c'est américain crinon
kevin en plus c'est complètement sortie
de madden en fait il aura de jolis là
sur f5 qui paraît fort parce que ça
cloud
et sa menace dame prend ya carrier
g-sync aux dalles prendre deux tons
price est mat trouve ça assez élégant
un
prénom irlandais parcelles tu
sais les irlandais voient qu'ils ont mis
à la mode aux états unis
je crois que ça va turbo gagner côté
russe on va voir
les prénoms vraiment américain et ses
passants comme vraiment comme prénom
parce que c'est surtout
les prénoms d'origine
si on dit étrangère ou à des gens qui
sont venus peupler les états unis
parce qu'ils ont comme prénom vraiment
typiquement américain
le prénom le plus bizarre pour moi en
anglais c'est le prénom dick je
comprends vraiment pas ce prénom
[Musique]
dick est un prénom très bizarre pour moi
je n'arrive pas trop à comprendre
ça existe vraiment ouais bah y'a pleins
prénom assez commun aux états unis dick
dit que c'est le motif de richard oui
mais bon teint tonton diminutif c'est
quand même
dommage qu'on voit que c'est un saint
diminutif mais enfin
je veux dire par là que comment comment
tu as a comme diminutif en fait
je comprends pas la logique en fait
je vais en fait c'est ça aucun rapport
c'est juste pour se [ __ ] de ta gueule
en fait
je comprends pas trop
voilà ces dames 5 aux dames 5 c'est joli
d'en prendre 5 ton prof sept matches
et dames 5 tours g7 vous finissez
comment à vous de jouer c'est très joli
très haut blanc
autour des 8 bien trouver dam des huit
tours h7 donc ça a dévié la dame roi
j'évite de me ranger cette maths
ça fait un point pour les russes cucq
deux points m voilà ça va faire un point
pour les américains
et ils ont les positions et les russes
ghachi
et ce prénom dit qu est ce qui a été dit
chez neo s vice-présidence et c'est
bizarre en fait c'est vraiment un prénom
je n'arrive pas à le comprendre ce
prénom
voilà c'est catastrophique il ya le pion
b2 qui tombe ça à faire deux points pour
les russes allaient manquera plus qu'un
point sur les quatre autres échiquiers
mais les russes lamanon sont vraiment
très très proches de la victoire
là ils s'approchent vraiment de la
victoire
à quelques encablures
ouais ça va partout en fait pour les
russes c'est que cette partie qui va pas
les deux pions mois
et ce à la russie elle s'est pas
complètement fini
il ya peut-être plus de game retourna
pour les vaisseaux messala après celle
échiquier
junior féminin
ouais ça peut encore tournicoter
s'est pas encore complètement finie pour
les américains
pendant les anglais qui est souvent des
prénoms pour parler de leur club
c'est quoi cette histoire en fait
ils sont complètement taré
la mef 6
bon ça a l'air bien de partout en pour
les russes là j'ai l'impression à chaque
fois qu'on voit une position enfin
dans ça s'est perdu en fait
non ça peut tourner fait cette partie là
si shang réussi à
déstabiliser double off
et à tout marc labrèche bien joué à toi
gagner ça fait un partout il manque il
manque deux points aux russes les points
qui pourraient prix
ouais en fait c'est important en fait la
partie à partie de l'eia là
est vraiment importante
si les ja gagne c'est quasi game
parce qu'après il manquera un point il
devrait être fait
il réellement il manque un point
derrière ça devrait être fait
après les russes sont aussi mieux autant
de partout 1
alors que l'agglo l'agglo peut encore la
gagner à yakaar temi afrique est dans le
dur
martin hirsch avait plutôt continue de
compter comme perdant perso
on est proche proche d'une victoire de
la russie ici
et au nord-ouest j'ai regardé un peu sur
le téléphone
ça va vraiment bien pour fuir ou déjà un
mais bon après faut faire attention ces
positions encore complexe et la wet
harry qui a battu dépôt des forces
pedneault didon méné peau du cou ça le
met mal aux lots non il perd quasiment
tout le bénéfice sur ce tournoi de ce
qu'ils avaient gagné dernièrement
ça va tellement vite les échecs en vrai
même ce qui fait moins 10 points 5e
mondial
après ouais je pense qu'il s'est testé
contre carl sel et maintenant ils jouent
un peu en roue libre 1
maintenant on époque il fait moins 10
points il suffirait que rapportent en
gagne une haie
et il revient
d'even top 4 du coup c'est
impressionnant et
surtout qu'on sait qu'à roanne à digoin
enfin on sait on sait justement pas trop
où ils en sont c'est vrai que c'est
hyper serré en réalité delà
de la 16e à la deuxième place mondiale
ça sert à rien les niveaux de joueurs
parce qu'entre car yakine qui est 16e et
caruana qui est 2e franchement ça se
tient dans un mouchoir de poche
en prime on est en cinquième a oui tu
peux être champion du monde en étant 100
lots même en
ce qu'elle est en train vraiment de
faire le taf là les ja
du beauf aussi
katia savard est en fête et les russes
sont vraiment vraiment pas loin de
gagner
là maintenant il ya tour ces trois tours
b un fou prend 1,3
ça va s'additionner
allez si les ja mais le point
il rapporte rapportera porte qui est pas
mal hein
donc ya pas deux il n'y a pas de matin
le piège c'était fou prend à droite
enfin cette façon je sais ce qui est
joué ces délices que j'allais dire
j'avais le chat qui cachait
la ccal idées sur fawcett
a le ton france et six prix ses six
enfants ça sert à rien oui kefu hessel
c'est vraiment fini tôt
à et là ça se passe bien et la tour qui
rendent par derrière et regarder la dame
bien placé pour pour les noirs
et là ça va rentrer par derrière
ouais donc à tous les points vont
rentrer elle n'a pas fait fouet cette
fable iii c'est aussi très sympa
elle menace tour c1
enfin faut prendre 3 et enfin way autour
c'est un cavalier d1 est
ok là il ya un piège vous prend 1,3 à
tour des huit matchs
fawcett ça me paraissait quand même plus
fort
avec deux beaux fils et mieux aussi un
champion qui courait ça va partout pour
pour les joueuses rude pour les joueurs
et les joueuses russes
sur tours 17 à la tour f 5
1 me 3 et peut-être prise pouces et 5
amira tout reprend b16 faut prendre
trois tours prend fou prend 1,6 à la
pâte raté quelque chose oh oui mais ça
se passe vraiment bien puisque artemiev
il va tenir là nul aussi ah oui non là
c'est artemiev la paire pas
annoncé en train de bien tourner partout
chez chez les russes
sont même quasiment à l'abri d'un
accident ici
kaléya le chien peut dans la colle
il ya le chien peut dans la colle pour
le moment
est double offre aussi à sachiez un peu
dans l'alcool l'a quand même
ça chie un poil dans la colle
ça à faire nul heureusement que
wes à chiens peu dans l'alcool de
partout là j'ai envie de dire ça veut
trop assuré sur toutes les parties
ne peut pas perdre 1 katia au pire ça va
sûrement faire nul
là ça va sûrement faire nul
donc pire ça fera 2 il manquera un point
sur les deux derniers
il ya normalement elle peut pas rater ça
quand même au pire nuit les forêts que
double facilement avec des doubles ou
nuls ouais donc on pire en full draw ça
va passer aussi en fait ils ont trois
belles positions et ils ont besoin de
fait ils ont besoin que deux nuls dans
des positions qui sont nulles ou
avantageuse
mais franchement c'est un peu chier dans
la colle
on va pas se mentir à la 17 ont peut
faire tout reprendre et dans le carré
car et ed
ça c'est drôle
et les ja os et les ja qui a
qui aurait pu tout à l'heure à voir qu'à
l'âge de plus
c'est cool pour alia pas tourcoing fc
est à la tour prends des seins
elle peut faire rager 7 et se replacer
brusca samson and when you tube sérieux
brousse ils arrêtent youtube c'est un
truc de ouf il va pas remettre ces
vidéos et tout sur youtube
non mais c'est n'importe quoi
c'est relou il est tellement du bon
contenu
pressée du rhin d'être créateur
c'est dur d'être créateur de contenu la
fougue 7 pouces et 5 aulas est en train
de tourner du golfe qui a obtenu la
nuque donc allez un ennemi
il va falloir faire là nul ici pour
faire 2
quelle galère vraiment les ja
rule à la sat choc un côté rouscoff
chupito
en et yala pas fort qu'elles fixent la
nulle
artemiev shiva qui va l'obtenir
et les ja qui serait kitsch au kit
kitsch au kit un peu attention de pas
missclick
intention de ne pas me ce clic
voilà normalement ça toi
tu dois faire drôle tu prends tu prends
et tu mets ton roi là
tu me diras elle est tellement gagnante
elle doit pas pas trop savoir où est ce
que là ça fait nul à l'oeil a besoin de
deux nuls pour les rouscoff et le match
et ai remporté bon ça c'est imperdable
ses pions de plus finale de foot
couleurs opposées
ingagnable aussi et donc ça va toujours
là dessus bon ben là tu prends des trois
tu prend 1,3 et tu fais draw et en parle
plus voilà
voilà
après ces gagnants se trouve que c'est
complètement gagnant avec le pion b en
plus
3,6 g 4 h 5 et à f5
normalement je pense fait plutôt roi des
six ici j'ai 4 h 5 voyages 5 direct très
bien joué et tu rentres
way il manque un point sur deux parties
6-3 b53 f53 c63 g4 trop d'avancé en fait
tu vas prendre prendre pierre prendre là
bas
ça ne peut que gagner
un f4 tu viens à tuffé g5 way
fait g5 encore plus facile roi prend
et si elle mise clique pas le match est
terminé ouais le pion h qui part
[Musique]
et oui c'est le troisième punto
donc là ça va même ça va faire deux
victoires chez les filles en au final
pour les rues c'est là le match est
officiellement
terminée les amis
voilà ça va faire nul et c'est fini les
russes s'impose
les subventions qui vont tomber
subventionnait d'
c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils gagnent
ces olympiades en ligne
et donc ouais ça fait trois nuls et deux
victoires deux fois trois et demi deux
ennemis victoire de la russie la pub qui
part et on va retourner faire des petits
blitz merci à tous les amis d'avoir
suivi cette compétition
en ma compagnie et ouais ma victoire de
la russie
voit sur
ça changera pas leur life les usa
peuvent tenter de se dé qu à huy et qu
aurait pu aurait pu sauver
bon bah tout de suite les gars mais